Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 18th, 2016 was going on to Hawaii.
Um, I don't know. I don't even know what,
I don't even know where to start on this fucker one.
Um, how do, how do you begin? This one is still be sensitive, sensitive.
There's so many sensitive stories out there and when there is,
when there's feelings there in
bold, um, this fucking
lie down at the zoo in Palm Beach, Florida, rest,
her soul got attacked and killed, got mauled, uh,
by a fucking tiger,
sometimes referred to as the tiger whisper, Yada, Yada, Yada, Yada, Yada,
Yada, Yada and all that fucking shit. These, I don't know what it
is about people who fall in love with wild animals. This,
there's nothing you can do to cure it. It's fuck it.
It doesn't give a fuck about you. It's not a dog.
You know, falling in love with a wild animal.
It's like falling in love with a stripper. Yeah.
It's just not going to end well. It's not going to end well.
Fucking unbelievable. None. There's another story.
This fucking scout leader takes a bunch of boys scouts,
takes a bunch of children into the fucking woods.
He goes into a cave and there's a fucking bear in there.
So the whole story's always an amazing that the boy scouts kept their fucking
cool. The guy knew, the scout leader knew.
He pulled his shirt up over his face and then curled up into the fetal position,
which I guess is the international bear signal like, hey man,
I don't want any part of this man.
And then the bear lost interest in walked away.
But at no point during all of this does anybody say,
Hey, what the fuck are you bringing a bunch of kids around with his bears just
walking around.
It's bad enough if you take your kids to the fucking zoo,
the amount of times he's Goddamn, things get loose. Or at the very least,
some fatties going to walk up to some polar bear cage,
go over the fucking thing and stand there, you know,
and then get fucking snatched by this thing. And what is she saying?
What for you? She fucking blow your brains out. You're dope. Right.
So I'm not saying the lady who died in Florida was a dope. I'm just saying that,
um, I don't know.
You Insert yourself into this situation and there's no good way to insert
yourself into a mauling to death by a tiger. Cause you know what that means.
There was also, they always just say malt. You know, like it came up like,
like some prison shit and just stuck you with the shank. It didn't,
it fucking crushed your neck and then it started feeding on your innards.
That's fucking brutal.
Okay.
Hang on a second, Nia. Okay.
What are you doing? You coming in? All right. Did you lock me in?
No.
Okay. Sorry. She just got, she's freaking me out. They're like, well,
I got these new locks on the door. I thought she was locking the door.
It's still early here and I just woke her up. So, uh,
she's going to be a little grumpy. Mia, if you want to come in on the podcast,
let me know. Oh,
that sandwich spoke volumes. You know, I'll tell you right now,
getting married is kind of like a falling in love with a wild land.
You know as much as you love them, don't get too close to the fucking in close.
Yeah. Um, yeah. Let me get back there.
Why the fuck would you take a bunch of kids out like no.
At no point does anybody address that.
This guy took a bunch of fucking children out to where there's bears and then
they watched him get fucking mauled for half a second before he took his izod
and yanked it over his head. That's what you're supposed to do.
Okay.
How have I been on the earth this long and not known that that's what you do
when you run into the bear?
Is it because I'm not in scouting or is it because most people are smart enough
to not be around bears?
To not reenact the fucking scene from the Leonardo DiCaprio movie?
What was it called? A rake on? I don't know what the fuck it is. The revelent,
the irrelevant, whatever the fuck it was called.
I hate when they take some big word that already exist and just makes you feel
like it's like, did they make that word up? And it's like, no,
that word is existed. The revenant. Right.
Okay.
That word is existed your entire life.
Just you and everybody you know is too dumb to walk around and use it on a daily
basis and yeah, that's, it's a sad feeling. Just sad fucking feeling. Um,
I forgot what I was looking. Oh yeah.
What to do if a bear attacks you,
I can tell you right now,
this is going to be 99.9% white people look in this shit up.
Let the, that go out there. I hate to do def jam material,
but it's fucking true.
Okay.
Jesus fucking Christ 2016 and he get mauled by a grizzly bear.
There's no excuse for that. And you know why? You know,
hallmark doesn't make a card for it. There you go.
You can go through all of that whole sympathy section. Sorry for your loss.
Sorry. It got this disease. Sorry, I was a Douche yesterday. There's no,
wow. Fucking sorry. You got mauled by a bear. They don't because it happens so,
so little. So few times. There's no reason for it.
They should really make one of those, you know, and, and make it even better.
It should like rhyme. Yeah.
I hate
to look, I hate to stare, but your face got mauled by a bear.
I'm really fucking sorry. Uh,
I know something about a trolley. Go Fuck Yourself. I'll help you feel
tension. All zookeepers out there. Uh, those are not your friends. Uh,
and they don't want to be there.
And I think a lot of them realize the situation.
Then I just sit there fucking waiting for you to give them another fucking pile
of cube steaks. They're sitting there, even if they were born in captivity,
I guaran fucking tee you that they are sitting there with this strange feeling
that there has to be more than this. Look at me too. Look, I mean,
if you're a fucking tiger, even you're a tiger born into captivity, right?
You're rolling around with somebody dressed in a safari outfit. Okay.
And you bond with that person like it's your fucking mother. Right?
It's some fucking point at some point,
you know, just g eagle alone with all those people showing up,
just to look at you taking your picture,
there's no weed and there's no way to keep your four feet on the ground,
you know, and not be like, dude, uh,
okay,
why am I in a cage right now when everybody's coming up? You know,
all I do is lay around every day and these people can't get enough looking at
me. I mean,
okay
man, I'm the fucking shit. You know, when you just start,
your ego just goes fucking cradling. Then you start looking like, you know,
I don't know, you'd start tested, they come in a little bit,
you give him a little growl,
you see it in their face and they got some broom handle. I get back to back,
right. You just Sorta, you know, first time with your park test,
the strength of that fucking little broom handle. Like, dude,
I could snap that thing. This guy's fucking shoulders, guy's a pussy.
You know what they're doing, tiger push up, you know?
And then one day you just like, you know what?
As much as I'm enjoying this fucking raw meat,
I have it every day and I need to switch up the Diet.
You know when I mall you and use your belt as some dental school.
Okay,
I know, I know what you're thinking right now. You probably think it pill.
This is really fucking insensitive. Well you know what,
this is how I deal with sad shit.
I joke around about it cause I don't feel like they get about everybody that
loved that woman that now can never see her again.
So I mean what am I supposed to do?
And then also I like to feel that I'm being responsible by giving you some tips
on how not to a, yeah. You know, well you know, get mauled to death by a bear.
I just don't understand that.
Like what's so fucking funny about these goddamn scouts,
it's like why don't you just go in the woods?
You don't have to go into the Goddamn wilderness. You know,
fuck brings a bunch of kids out there. I'll tell you,
it brings a bunch of kids out there,
kind of guy that goes out and just walks into a fucking cave,
gets mauled by a fucking bitch.
Who the fuck walks into a cave in the middle of the forest? What kind of,
I mean, I'm not in scouting. I never was. I can't start a fire without a match.
But I can tell you right now,
my general instincts say is that says that you know,
there's no apartment buildings out in the fucking forest. Okay,
so a cave is like, that's like a townhouse in Brooklyn.
You know, half the people have to fucking dig into holes in the Goddamn ground,
curling up to hibernate. And then here's a fucking cave. All right,
so you think everybody who lives out there, that's like fucking,
that's like Beverly hills level property. So who's going to get it?
The strongest, sickest, craziest motherfucker out there. And that's a bear.
You know,
you're not going to walk in there and there's going to be a little fox in there
like it isn't. It's going to be some fucking,
it's got to be the king of the forest. Which is a bear as far as I know.
Although I did see a mountain lion give it a couple of fucking, you know,
personnel Whitaker's, you know, Mimo fast. That guy was,
they would just fucking right on top of this head.
And the bear just sat there and taking, you know,
he had like the head movement of light of late Mike Tyson rather than early in.
He just took a few and then he just sorta started running away was a sad day,
you know? Um, anyways,
just imagine if you ran into a badger or a fucking wolverine.
Those are the lunatics,
badges and wolverines still like the Irish and the Scottish of the fuck it
forest. You know what I mean?
Okay.
Those things don't even quit. Even, even if they're losing,
they just got dead. I don't give a fuck, you know, blood all over their face.
They're not stopping. They're going to keep coming.
Just like the Irish and the Scottish fucking loaded ticks.
You don't want any part, any part of that? Well, you know,
I don't know what I mean. You know,
I never even looked to say Kate bear encounters in back country.
If you encounter a bear on the trail or in your campsite. Yeah,
cause you're cooking food. Basically the dinner bell of anything within fucking,
oh my God. Look at the size of this fucking bear. Oh,
there's a lady fucking walking in. There's a bear in the background.
Guess what color she is. Alright. Be Safe and bear habitat.
Oh God. This is the first sentence. The level, I mean,
as dumb as I am, the level of dopes that have to become to this website. Listen,
this is the first sentence. It's normal. It's normal.
T I said normal. It's normal to be frightened when you encounter a bear.
That's how this, this is. This is the jump off point.
The reality is that most encounters with bears rarely,
rarely lead to aggressive behavior. And attacks are even rarer. Here.
They go sucking you into the forest and you know, I mean it happens,
but generally is, here's a great lie.
They're actually more afraid of you than you are of them. Yeah.
And what are they doing when they get, when they're afraid. Okay?
They either take off running or they fucking maul you to death and go, hey,
you know, here's a bonus. The threat is gone and now I have a midday snack.
Remember, most bears prefer to avoid contact with humans.
Okay,
that's hilarious. Still like the champion that doesn't want to fight. You know,
just trying to hold onto the belt back paddle in the entire time until you
corner the fucking thing.
And any bear you do see is probably just as frightened as you are there.
It is every fucking, you know what it is.
The bears don't have access to a mirror.
They're living in their heads, you know, they're out there by themselves,
you know, talking to themselves account man, you know,
not to find a cave or some shit, man. Right? And all of a sudden,
so they finally find it, nobody else is in here. You can fucking chill out,
put an l shape couch over here, get a flat screen.
And all of a sudden this fucking guy comes walking in and his God damn shorts.
You know what he's thinking, he's thinking to catch a predator.
He's probably seen that show too. He comes this fucking pedophile,
the bear thinks he's going to get fucked in the ass.
And next thing you know he's on top of this guy, right?
And a fucking dudes dodge yanking his shirt over his head.
And then the bear is like, what the fuck? Sky's a bottom. You know,
I thought this guy was trying to rape me. Now all of a sudden he's acting like,
well, make it love here. And he's being all submissive.
This is fucking weirded me out.
What if he tells his friends the bears all homophobic and then he kills him and
why? You know what? There's a bunch of little kids watching it. All right?
And that's what camping is. And I think, you know what?
I have to haven't worked that out right there.
I think scouring should be illegal. You know what I mean? We want to get doing,
first of all, you know, dressing those little boys up like little French maids,
you know, Darryl scarfs running around. I mean,
it's just you wonder why you got all those sexual predators, sex predators,
sexual predators. I don't. It's sexual chocolate. Um, anyways,
remained as composed as possible and follow these simple guidelines.
Whenever you're in bear country, soon you will,
you two will have more composure when siting a bear because you know what to do
a scream bloody murder and run in the other direction. Actually,
it's exactly the exact opposite of what you want to do. You want to remain calm.
It take a step towards the bear that shows a level of confidence.
[inaudible]
fucking dopes. Alright, first one, avoid. Avoid, avoid.
Yeah. Light. By staying in civilization,
the best way to prevent an unpleasant and unpleasant bear encounter is to avoid
them all together.
Bears usually avoid people and most people don't even know when they,
they've come close to a bear. Exactly.
To insure a surprise or an to ensure a surprise or unpleasant encounter with a
bear doesn't occur.
Avoid moving through bear habitats silently and alone traveling groups.
The larger the better.
And make lots of noise by talking or singing and put the iPod away and pay
attention to your surroundings. Ah,
Jesus Christ. I don't know about that.
What if the bears have an a slow fucking couple of days and is hungry and you
starts, you know, um, get into Rhames school. Lido.
We do what we do. Zip Petito does it. Beatty. Yay. You know,
and the bear starts sick. You like, you know what? I think it's worth the risk.
Even though I'm scared. I think I could take that fucking 140 pound dope.
All right. When it happens, she,
they wrote that instead of when you're getting mauled by the bear and you fail,
it's breath and his fucking incisors ripping at your neck when it happens.
That's another way of saying that. Remain calm and ready.
Your bear spray or other deterrent. What is it?
Your underarm here, uh, stay together. If you're in a group,
you will appear larger and more intimidating. If you stick together,
try to figure out whether the bear is a grizzly or a black. Hey,
let's fake run that is 40 miles an hour.
If a dog that's over right fucking over,
try to figure out whether the bears a grizzly or a black bear.
As you will see below,
grizzly bears and black bears tend to behave differently in a given situation,
so it helps to know which species you're dealing with as it's running.
After you give me a fucking break, I just click here to see the difference
bears at a distance. Dude, it's a fucking bear.
Look at these fucking things.
Do the fact that one of these things could pick up Lawrence Taylor at the height
of his fucking career and throw him through the uprights. You
gotcha. Bear Smart Society. These, these fucking people like I don't get it.
I mean there has to be,
why can't you just go out and your backyard just set up a tent? I mean you,
you are still outside. As long as you don't go inside, you are camping.
It's not the same thing, man. I've got to get out there where there's bears.
I know what to do, right? If it's a black bear, black bear,
they usually lead with the left. You know what I mean?
The traditional of Grizzlies is south park,
so it's going to be a little bit weird.
They definitely have a reach advantage considering when they stand up.
They're about eight feet tall.
So what you want to do is you want to stay outside his wheelhouse. Okay.
And you want, you want to circle away from his power pants.
You want to circle to your left staying away.
He's the craziest want to load up that left that go for the big shot.
They tried to steal around. I don't know. I'm sorry.
Am I beating this to death here? I'm just, there's no fucking reason.
There's no reason to get killed by a tiger in the United States of America.
They don't live here.
There are only one place there at the fucking zoo at uh,
you know they're in cages self.
At some point you went into the fucking thing. You do just you, I don't know.
Oh my God. What is the fucking thought when you get yanked in the second year?
Oh No, it's gotta be it. Oh No,
make it quick. I mean, just shit that would go through your head. I'm sorry.
This is getting fucking morbid. Um, so anyways, my condolences to the,
uh,
friends of families or the lady down there in Florida and made condolences to
the, uh,
the girl with the members only jacket that he yanked up over his fucking head.
Uh, you know, good. I knew, sir.
I hope I wish you more luck as you bring children into the fucking woods.
Fucking idiot.
What is it about putting on a fucking uniform that all of a sudden you think you
know something? I just don't get it. Oh, I are you off.
I have all my badges on my shirt. I've been trained
thanks Phi. He's a jolly good fellow.
That's so they should be singly sure thing that, you know,
we're never going to see you again. Music, right before you go in the woods,
just to fucking remind you of what you're walking into. Um, anyways,
so, hey, um, the official, finally
the official hour, um,
I'm allowed to finally say F is for family has been picked up for a second
season. Um, I actually got the news back in January,
but for whatever reason, the way Netflix promote stuff,
which I would never question considering they're dominating the universe.
They wanted to wait until last Friday. So it is now official. Uh,
we are working right now.
That's the stuff I've been alluding to that a I'd been working on and I'm,
uh, I wasn't going to say, ah, actually, this weekend I was writing an episode,
so I missed all the fucking hockey.
I saw the series that I'm watching in St Louis First,
the Black Hawks, and when I saw game two,
I threw in the fucking towel. I was like, that's it.
You gave a game to the black cock. She cannot give a game to the hawks.
You know, you had your foot on their fucking neck. He had the goal.
The goal was fucking called back or whatever. I can't remember what happened.
The goal got called back, right?
Or Tara Cincos Gore got called back and then it's just like,
that coach should have gone down the bench. No, let down. No let down. Right.
What do they do? They go out there. They're pissed terrorists.
Sanko takes a stupid fucking penalty. The black cock score,
the goal and they steal the fucking game and I was just like,
and I was texting my buddy. I was like,
that right there is why the Blackhawks win every fucking year in St Louis loses
every fucking year. Whatever.
The Blackhawks have that ability to remain calm when they're down St Louis for
my whole fucking life has never had that right.
The rain half day set all of that shit. What are they doing?
Game three I didn't see the game. I just looked at the highlights.
You know they took three quick penalties in the first period.
Chicago scored on the first, on the first one. If I was watching that game,
I'd be like, here we go, here we go.
Chicago's going to win like the next for the next four to five and then I'm
going to give them, they're even St Louis Seal right there.
Fred St Louis came back,
tied it up one one Chicago scores a goal in the second period, two to one.
They're going into the third period in Chicago. This is always said,
you know, it's over for the blues. It's always been that way since,
I don't know how long it's been going on forever now.
Like the Blackhawks were good my whole life. I mean shit,
they went through a nice drug too.
But like the new Blackhawks like this series is over and,
and fucking St Louis came back, tied it up to two and then went ahead three,
two with like six minutes left.
And so a big congratulations to uh,
the St Louis Blues, that huge fucking victory.
And I can't wait to see the next game cause I know the black and [inaudible].
Then I just got to go out like that. Right. You know,
they're going to tie it up. They're going to go into St Louis. This might go a,
I don't know, I'll make go seven. I'm open for seven. You know,
I don't give a shit, but I'm, I'm pulling for St Louis. I think they,
my team over Dallas, just because, you know, Dallas was the north stars,
right? They've only been Dallas stars for like, what, like 20 years. Eh,
you know, I mean those people down, they, they a bunch of cowboys who's kid who,
you know, they getting plastic surgery, you know, they get their oil welded,
wife's wearing too much makeup. I mean the different Dallas, the big D,
it's a football town to football state. I love the fucking stars.
I love the people on the stars. But like I also like they're fucking colors.
They got Celtic colors. I like to, I still like to stars, but you know, I think,
I don't think it's time for the blues. They've been around since 67.
They never want shit. So that's the team I'm pulling for.
[inaudible] how come you not rooting for the Boston Bruins?
Because we didn't make the playoffs. Um,
but who would've thought a black cock sit down two games to one to the blues and
the kinks are down o two to the San Jose shacks.
Um, and actually a buddy of mine who writes onF is for family before this all
started. He goes, I don't give a fuck. He goes,
the Stanley Cup goes through Chicago or la.
And that's what everybody was saying. Now, granted,
we're only a couple of games in here and granted the kings are playing the
sharks and, and you know,
the sharks are like the San Diego chargers if they were skates, you know,
every year coming out having this wonderful fucking regular season,
and then they go in the playoffs and they just shit the bed. So we'll see.
They were up two games to none. Um, I think game four,
if you haven't been watching is Tuesday night, uh, the Black Cox first to blue.
So I will definitely be checking that out. And, um, I think that's it.
I think that's all I had on hockey, right? My Celtics,
I watched some lose game one,
but I'm just so psych they're in the fucking playoffs and are there young team,
they should've won the game. They should've been able to close it out.
They didn't, but they hung in there. They got had that just a little young.
They just got to learn how to fucking a filler, hopefully. You know what I mean?
Oh, no, you don't. I'm hoping, I'm hoping that we get Kevin Duran.
He would be a great fucking Celtic. Uh, whether he does that or not,
I mean there's always someplace, uh, you know, what's this?
This is the most crucial time. Yeah. And I,
since I can remember for the Los Angeles Lakers where Colby just fucking
retired. Okay. Their owner fucking died too. Now they got the son
Fuck head that he is sorry, that had nothing to do with the Lakers.
I was just quoting what movie was that and then your son Fuck head that he is
okay.
Left drivers less to romance. Um, yeah,
they have to make something happen.
They got to throw their fucking money around. I Dunno,
they don't have the coach, they don't have it. This could be for the first time.
You realize that the Lakers have one more fucking championships since 1970 than
any other team in any other major sport. Um,
so I gotta respect what they've done more so than what anybody else has done
prior to that.
Because prior to that was the 23 skidoo years where the shit was in fucking
basically black and white, you know, segregated leagues.
The Stanley Cup was the size of a shot glass. You know,
the Celtics used to win that would be like fucking five white guys against five
white guys or maybe five against four white guys.
And then Bill Russell was out there. You know what I mean? It's just,
it's just a completely different time, you know? Um,
I don't know. We'll see. So anyways, let me do a little bit of advertising here.
Sorry. My brain is all over the place and I just still can't get over.
How fucking people getting mauled 20 1620 fucking 16.
I mean,
to get mauled to death by a fucking tiger in 2016 it's,
it's like, I don't know, I have to take it.
I think the probability of getting run over by a stagecoach is,
is just as probable. Like how many people get, you know what I to look that up,
death by stagecoach is, you know, this can be somebody. Some wow.
What show when Oklahoma fell off the chuckwagon. Okay. You know,
it's going to be a guy to man killed under stage coach.
Let's see if we get to see we get, did you mean man killed under stage coach?
One word. I guess I did unsettling events.
Stagecoach robberies, police id man killed in, stole crash,
fatal crash on stagecoach road.
72 year old man was killed Sunday morning after a crash in
West Lake Lynn Township and the authority said a vehicle traveling northbound on
road. Ah, I guess it doesn't happen and whatever.
Somebody get kicked by a horse or something stupid.
Something that should be happening during this time.
But why can't you just admit that you are wrong? All right, I was wrong.
It's more probable to get mauled to death by a tiger. All right, let's uh,
let's do treat some of the advertising here. I do Ali Shave Club.
Everybody Dollar Shave club.com has his special offer to new members who join
today.
You get a free month of the executive razor when you buy a two book Dr Cabbies,
easy shape.
This is the first time they've ever done something like this and once you tried
dollar shave club.com you'll be,
you'll become a proud member like millions of others.
Just puffing your chest out as you walk down the street. I get cheap razors.
What are you doing with your life?
One reason is because they deliver amazing razors right to your door for a third
of the price of what the greedy razor corporations charge.
That means when you join DSC,
you can afford to shave with a fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic. You feel you're running a bank, right?
Um, you get a first class shave when you use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet. Another reason is Dr Carver's shave butter can't bleed.
It's not carvings. I'm using it with the executive.
Makes the blade glide gently for the smoothest shave ever.
Dr Carver's shave butter.
Dr Caddies isn't your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin feeling unbelievably smooth and soft and right now,
new members who buy a tube of the shave butter get the executive razor for free.
A, they've never done this before.
Take advantage of it and it's only available by going to dollar shave
club.com/bird that's dollar shave
club.com/bar now Jesus Christ, how many have I got this week? All right.
Trunk Club,
Trunk Club Trunk Club was started to solve a simple problem.
Shopping for clothes in stores is overwhelming and inconvenient.
It's not overwhelming. It's sucks. Who wants to do that?
[inaudible] at least I don't. I don't want to fucking do that.
So if I don't want to do that, then I assume everybody else doesn't.
Thank God for Trunk Club.
Cause with trunk club you'll discover great clothes that are perfect for you.
Oh look at this shirt without ever having to go shopping.
We combined top brands, experts,
service and unparalleled convenience to deliver a highly personalized,
personalized experience that helps you look.
Your best trunk club is not a subscription service.
We send you clothes only when you ask zero sign up or monthly fees.
Yeah, you can't ask for anything more than that. Look at that. You know,
they'll send you a shirt whenever you want.
We sent trunks refrain from saying boxes eludes to subscription service.
I didn't. I said, what the fuck you wrote?
Why would you put that sentence in the copy? You know, I'm going to read it. Uh,
don't talk about price. Talk about quality. Hey,
don't tell me what the fuck to do. I'm reading. Why don't you just write,
what the fuck you want me to read? You assholes.
How did this go from copy to them wagging their finger at me?
I'll talk about whatever the fuck I want to talk about. You know,
if you want to go to the fucking mall, this is the great thing. Okay?
They gotta, I mean, I can paraphrase all this. They have an expert stylist.
In other words,
someone who eventually will actually get paid at decent amount of money to pick
out these clothes. But right now they're new to the business.
So take advantage of their talents while they still work for trunk club. Okay?
You tell them your basic styles. I like concert tee shirts and flip flops,
whatever your fucking deal is. And then they'll get somebody to go out.
They pull a bunch of shit, they stick it in the trunk, they send it to you,
you keep what you want, you take everything else you don't want.
You throw it back in the fucking trunk and you send it back to them and that's
it. And they don't send you any more shit until you ask them to consider down a
subscription service. All right. If you'd like to take advantage of this,
go to fucking wherever the hell it is. Trunk Club
please. No mention of competitors. I don't even understand this. There's,
this is like a, this was more a letter giving me shit for what I've been doing.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to say it's trunk club.com/birth that's what I would go with a MVMT
watches. You know,
it's been a few weeks now since I cracked open these sharp looking, Eh,
Jesus Christ. Why do they keep doing this to me?
Why do they keep they,
they probably sent this copy out to every person with the podcast and everybody
goes, you know,
it's been a few weeks since I cracked open these sharp looking movement.
Watch boxes. I did. I saw them. They're fucking great.
They look like expensive watches and you know,
but I am a fucking 48 year old man,
so I have an expensive watch and I'm going to continue wearing that.
If I was in my twenties or my early thirties, if I had gone through a divorce,
these are the fucking watch for you, okay?
So you can still attract some expensive tail. All right. Without, you know,
you'll still have money to buy her a drink. That's basically it. All right.
If you haven't a chance to experience how movement watch fits around your wrist,
this is the chance movement. Watch you start it. Just $95.
See when movement cut out the middleman with the huge big bank brand markups,
the price of a watch. Finally got affordable. Imagine that. Exclamation point.
A watch with the department store quality for a fraction of the price. Okay,
so if you want one of those things, go to MVMT. Um,
MVMT watches.com/bar and they'll give you 15% off your entire purchase.
MVMT watches.com/bar. All right, stamps.com everybody
stamp [inaudible] dot com this is the last one. All right,
stamps.com everybody trips to the post office are never convenient.
So why not get postage right from your desk with stamps.com stamps.com even
gives you special postage discounts you can't get at the post office,
including first-class priority mail express international [inaudible].
You'll never pay full price for postage. Again. Here's how stamps.com works.
Your own computer and printer buying print official US postage for any letter or
package. Then hand, it's your mail.
Then you mail to the mail man or drop it in a mailbox. It's that easy.
No wonder over 600,000 small businesses already use stamps.com I use Stan.
Stop calm anytime. I have my posters when I'm pouring myself out.
After my shows, I send them out.
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to use this shit. So can you right now,
sign up for stamps.com using my last name, burr for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a postit including postage
and a digital scale. Don't wait. Get started with stamps.com today.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else, click on the microphone.
At the top of the homepage and type in birth, B u r that stamps stock.
[inaudible] all righty. They had had that down.
But then at dad, they don't take care of that fucking to death by a tiger,
you know, fucking, you know,
attacked by a bear in the wilderness as you're walking around with fucking
20 children that aren't yours. I mean,
that sounds like an episode of law and order. Boop, boop, boop. Ooh.
Like what the fuck were you doing out with, with all of those kids? I found a,
um, all right. My gym got delayed by some bullshit,
you know, not some bullshit, just some shit. And I'm just like, no, do it.
Right. Like, we can do it this way or we can do it the right way. I'm like,
do it the right way. So, um,
I have not been working out and I've been eating like shit because I'm just
like, well, the second that Jim's there, I'm gonna fucking go like a mad man.
But, uh, Jim's taking longer than I thought. And, uh, you know,
oh Billy started to look like some overcook mashed potatoes and I'm not liking
it. I'm not liking it bit. Um, all right, let's, let's do some reads here.
Let's do some reads. Oh, you know what,
I didn't talk about any of the other playoff series today or the, you know,
the other NHL, the uh,
the filthy fliers it down to o to the Washington capitals. And uh,
they are, they are the perennial favorites in the, uh, the eastern conference.
Uh, let's see, real quick.
Tampa Bay lightning leads Detroit two one Detroit one the last one.
They fucking red backs up against the ropes. Big victory there.
Islanders over the Florida. Two Games to one.
Nashville's up two games to none of a fucking anime. Oh, this sucks. Bad.
Fucking the kings and the ducks are going to get knocked out. No playoff hockey,
bro. Fucking freckles out here. There. Dallas is up two games to none.
Um,
I'm completely in the dark with all of this bullshit cause I'm going to be in a
writers room. I'm in the writer's room for the next olds.
18 weeks total to write the uh, the second season. And believe it or not,
I'm actually finding that I love being in the writers room.
I thought it was something that I was not going to enjoy because of the freedom
that I has as a comedian,
but it turns out I really like writing scripts and I like writing dialogue and
all of that Shit and, uh,
we're having a great time and I think you guys hopefully are gonna enjoy it.
So now your next question should be built. How many episodes did they give you?
10, 10 episodes for, um, season two.
And when is it going to be at? When is it going to come out? Probably uh,
this time next year. It's animation. That's how long it takes. Um,
I think they're saying may of next year is when it comes out, unfortunately.
But uh, that's how it works. But it's going to be worth the wait.
But I hope it now that we're kind of going, that once we do this,
when we can immediately go into season three, I don't know how it fucking works.
I guess that wouldn't make sense.
They got to see how many people watch season two?
I don't know.
I think by the time we finished season five, I'll be 60.
That's what I'm guessing. All right, let's do some questions here for the week.
Uh, come to Prague, come to Prague. Um, I'd like to go to pro.
Hey Billy. Wingnut just so you know, we started using your songs at circle time.
Circle time is every morning at nine 15 after yoga. It is, it is.
Songs in words and learning English. All the kids singing our check kids,
please come to Prague.
[inaudible]
the fuck is circle time.
Okay.
Sounds oddly filthy. Uh, circle time.
Prague,
Prague, link, linguistics circle homepage.
The fuck. I don't, I ain't know what that means. I can't tell you this.
So I've stuck with the French have 51 fucking days and now it's starting to just
be in my head. I still can't speak it. Well, if somebody's speaking it, I,
I pick out a few words, but like reading it, I'm crushing it. Reading.
I read the, I transcribed this whole fucking article about the pope saying that,
you know, as much as the Catholic church has been against condoms,
there are certain instances, you know,
that they don't think it's bad to use them. Um, you know, especially preventing,
um, the spread of HIV, aids, whatever, you know,
and they said something about, you know, unprotected sex with male prostitutes.
I think that that's what it said.
I couldn't tell if it was that or men going to prostitutes.
I couldn't quite get the translation. So, uh, I'm sticking with it. And um,
cause on dual lingo too, if you, if you do a hundred days in a row,
they give you a couple of trinkets, whatever the fuck that means. So I'm, I'm,
I'm over the hump of Brian Downhill now. And um,
I dunno, I just think I'm just, I'm really doing it.
Not only did I want to learn how to do it, but I just think it's funny.
If someone is dumb as me becomes completely fluent in French and then that gives
me the opportunity to go to France or go to Montreal and act like the dumb
American and then listen to what they're saying about me and then just fucking
hit them over the head with some fucking, I can't say perfect French,
but like fluent French. Just watch their fucking,
their little fucking pocket squares get all fucking in a bunch.
That's why I'm doing it. I'm doing it. I was going to take,
I don't know how long it's going to take me. I just,
I want to have that moment just once in my life where I could just sit there and
have somebody trashing me in a different language and they don't know that I can
hear everything.
I understand everything that they're saying just so I can look at them and then
fucking come back and I'm like, GVD buddy. They basically saying like,
I knew exactly what the fuck did you said? Right. Um, all right. Sorry.
Most people want to learn it so they can communicate. Not me, not me.
I want to do it so I can have an argument on the other side of the world.
What does that say about me? Alright, a cooking question. Dear Billy,
the butter basting bitch.
Ah, that was
a, Oh, see, there you go. There you go. Something original.
I liked that made fun of my cooking. You kept the alliteration going.
You called me a bitch in the end of it. I give that one four stars. Four stars.
All right. Uh, anyways, uh, I am a huge fan and I blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
Yada, Yada, Yada. My question is, thank you for blowing through all that.
My question is, you used to talk about cooking all of the time,
but now you rarely do what gives. Did you stop cooking? Uh, if not,
what have you made lately? Please make more cooking videos.
Like the pie crust one you made. I need something new to jerk off to.
Thanks and go fuck yourself. Um, yeah, I haven't been cooking. I've, um,
when I, uh,
when we write these episodes for afters for family,
I'm so fucking relieved I can finally talk about this shit. Um,
it consumes my life. I mean, I basically, I go in at 10 30 every morning.
There's usually some other bullshit I have to do.
So I'm usually in there by 10 in the morning and then we fucking right all day
til about seven. And by the end of it, I just come home.
I pull out a scotch, I stare at the wall, I fall asleep,
my dog wakes me up at seven. I take her for a walk,
I come home, I have breakfast,
I try to bang out a podcast and maybe do a little bit of French,
and then I go right back to work. So I don't have time to fucking do anything.
Um, you know, I should do, I should start using blue apron. You know,
I saw Mark Marin, he actually cooked a meal on it. It looked fucking delicious.
Um, but I, uh, I should really start doing something like that because I have,
I've been eating like a sort of in a good way, in sort of bad way.
I had the best mother fucking Burger I've ever had in Los Angeles and that is
saying something and if you'd like to know where to go the next time you see me
when you're in Los Angeles, you ask me. I will tell you where the places,
but I'm not saying it on a podcast because I hate when Anthony Bordain does that
and this is cool fucking spot. And then he makes it, he makes it fucking,
you know, every Tom,
Dick and Harry's got to go out there and then it comes on a new management.
The whole thing gets fucked up. So,
or even if I'm out on the road from on the road,
just yell it out during my show. You Hey bell with that good burger spot.
You in La, you know, you bought a ticket, I'll tell you.
Then he listened to this podcast for free. You don't get the information.
Oh, is it delicious? The fries were okay. The Soto was, you know,
they had the Mexican fucking coke in the, a fan to orange with the real sugar.
Incredible credible tasting. That's what's where this country is right now.
Coca-Cola is made better in Mexico than it is in the United States.
What does that say about us? You know, and it's Donald Trump,
Hillary Clinton or fucking Bernie Sanders even approach that at any point during
the this, this campaign they might have. Lord knows I'm not watching.
All right. So, um, no where I last left,
I was trying to learn how to make Gnocchi and I failed miserably.
And my own wife, the woman who's supposed to love me unconditionally,
sickness and health in good times and in bad. And when I made Gnocchi,
it was a bad time. And what did she do? Did she stick by me?
Did she say it's okay and rubbed my head? Nope. You know what she said?
She leaned over and she goes, hey. And I was like, what? She got right me here?
And she goes, you shouldn't make pasta anymore. She said,
you shouldn't make pasta anymore. You know,
maybe she knows me well enough to know that it's,
when somebody says something like that to me, that just makes me go, all right,
I'm going to fucking master this shit. You know? I mean, it's not like,
you know, if somebody says you shouldn't sing anymore,
well you shouldn't dance anymore. I maybe I understand that. I mean, I fucking,
there's just certain things, but I mean, cooking is just one of those things.
Like, you just do it. You'll, you can learn how to do it.
Like all these fucking people on the food network, they don't have any,
they don't have any talent. It's just, they just, you know,
they didn't have any friends and they just fucking, you know,
they started off making cereal and then they just kept progressing. I'm kidding.
I know. It's an art form. All right. Fucking relax. Okay.
Put your apron back on and go fucking make a souffle. All right. So, um, yeah,
so I'm kind of stuck on that. But the next time I go to New York,
I met somebody. Um, I met somebody, it's very special.
I met somebody in New York, uh,
a chef at this Italian restaurant and he told me, he's like the real deal,
like right off the boats and anytime he come to New York he goes,
I'll show you how to make pasta from scratch, blah blah blah.
Cause I took a pasta making class and uh, uh,
they were supposed to then email a bunch of shit to help you out and they never
had any follow through.
And then I waited too long to try it again and I finally,
I kind of forgot some of the tricks. So, um,
that's where I'm at with the cooking thing.
And as far as making like the cooking videos,
I did the pie crust thing cause that was another thing.
I just thought it was funny.
Someone like me knows how to do something like that, but like I,
I can't cook better than most of the people out there,
so I don't understand the point of it. Um, maybe if I,
if I learned how to make Gnocchi, I'll teach you guys how to do it,
but I have to do it for a long time before I'll feel like confident enough to
make a video. Maybe if I fuck it up, it'll be funny. I had no idea. All right,
let's, let's keep reading here, shall we? Okay. All right. Garden.
We do, we top soil.
One of my favorite things you used to talk about was your garden and your steps
towards getting off the grid.
My question is do you still have a garden and are you still taking steps to get
off yourself off the grid? Um, ah, that,
I mean I have a lemon and a lime tree so I'll never get scurvy.
Um,
no, I just,
the level of like commitment that that takes and you have to have like a fucking
henhouse and shit, you know,
I don't have time to become Mr. Green jeans and then what do I have to have a
Henhouse guy? I have to have the chicken guy. You know what I mean?
It's like as you accumulate shit, then you have to get the something guy,
right? Yeah. You buy a fucking house, you immediately, he,
you'd have a plumber. You got to have a fucking electrician, you know,
you got to have a, basically a handyman. Okay. Then what?
Then you have a garden.
Then you got to have a fucking landscaper gardening guy because you're too busy
doing whatever you do for a fucking career, a living. You get a pool,
you need the pool guy, you know, you get a dog,
you got the fucking dog guy, the vet guy, all of that shit.
It's just more money flying out of your fucking wallet. And I'm
okay.
I am very envious of people that have their own gardens and that type of shit.
But, uh, I, you know, I have my little piece of fucking
La out here, which is not much. We all live on top,
which I'm literally looking out my window right now and I see the roof of the
person's house next to me. That's just basically how it works,
you know? And I look out the back,
I look out my back window and I see the apartment buildings,
the back of the apartment buildings from the street over.
There's really not a place to plant some turnips, although I wish there was.
And I don't think I could really get away with like having fucking chickens and
shit. Some rooster crowing every morning cause uh,
the noise ordinance is noise is not supposed to leave your property.
Although most people the second they turn on their stereo,
they break that fucking thing. But um, I would love to do it.
I'd love to get solar panels and be off the grid, but you really can't be,
you still have to give them a little bit of money. I forget.
I don't know how it works, but they have some, so I know how it works.
The president makes 400 grand a year, so he, they go, yes, listen, fuck,
oh you want the second term, make this a law. We said break it a lot, right?
Next thing you know,
it's a law because there's people live in the middle of nowhere.
The electric company finds them. And then they like,
they show them and like you have to give us money every month, which is,
I just don't understand how that is.
Legal debt goes around so many things that this country is allegedly about.
If someone would force you, I understand taxes. So like, yeah dude,
you want to live here? You got to kick in for the puddles. I get that.
But you have to buy power from this fucking no, don't fuck off.
But that's not how it works. It's not our works. If you guys know how to do it,
if you how to get off the grid,
by all means not cause I want to be off the grid now cause I give a fuck that I
give money to the power companies. I just, you know, when the shit hits the fan,
I would like to be that beacon of light that all the zombies run to right.
He's still got a fletch. Great. Um, alright girlfriends. Wait.
Oh Jesus. Here we go. Dear Bill, I'm a 21 year old guy. My girlfriend is 20.
We've been taped.
We've been talking for about six months now and we just recently decided to make
it official. Now here's the part where I need your expert advice. Old Jesus.
How should I go about telling her? I think she needs to lose weight.
She's not a fat ass by no means, but she could lose a few pounds.
Now I sound now I sound like an ass. I know. I sound like an Asshole,
I think is what he's supposed to say. Yeah, I know he sound like an asshole,
but I care about her and want to see her be more confident. Thanks for the help.
I enjoyed the show in Long Beach. Um,
I didn't say she could lose it there. There is no way a,
what I would do is I would get yourself in great shape and start getting her
into hiking with you and like, uh, you know,
but you can't make somebody work out. You can't make somebody get in shape.
They either want to do it or they don't. And um,
okay.
You know, that's like a major, major, major fucking,
you know, you tell telling a woman she needs to lose a few pounds.
It's like that, like that's the female equivalent of them saying to you like,
you know, your Dick could be a little
bigger.
It's devastating. Um,
I wouldn't say it to her, but, uh, you know, you also got to think, you know,
at 20th they could lose if they're already getting out of shape at 20 years of
age, you know, then what?
Then they have a couple of kids that going to be a fucking house. I mean,
that's just something you get,
you gotta be honest about if someone doesn't take care of themselves,
you know, and this works both ways too, ladies.
Like if you're with some guy and he's in his twenties and he's sitting there and
he's already getting man tits, it's, it's not going to get better. And,
uh, you got to sit there and, and really just be like, how much do I, uh,
love this person?
Because I'm going to watch them slowly eat themselves to death.
Cause that's what you're doing. And unfortunately, um,
you chicken start coming home to roost in your forties,
whatever the fuck you did,
whenever you started to go off the rails at 16 or 17 with drinking, drugging,
eating, or whatever,
right around when you get to your forties is when the first like,
like God damn that happened to him. I thought that was some old man shit.
And you're like, oh wait, we're in our forties,
because you'll still feel like you're in your 20s. So,
um,
I dunno, I would go a positive route.
I would just tell her how I would tell her. Uh, Oh,
you tell her how good she looked at me. That's just fucking, I don't,
there's no way to do it that that is, there's no,
that's a fortress in, there's no door in. You know what I mean?
There's no door in on that one. You just have to just,
if you're going to say it, if he just fucking say it,
then you're really risking like, uh, hurting her really bad.
You know what I mean? Um,
and who wants to do it? You don't, you don't want to fucking do that, you know?
I wonder if women ever feel that way about guys.
Like if there's anything like this, like, you know what?
You just can't say that to a guy because that will hurt them too much.
Do they ever think shit like that? I think shit like that with women.
This just certain things you just, you just don't fucking say like,
what is all I'm going to do is hurt her in ruiner for the next person when she
fucking eventually comes to her senses and dumps me. Um,
and then you'll be that, you know what this guy said to me one time,
we were going into weapons
and I ordered a double cheeseburger. Eddie interrupted. He said, no, no, no.
She wants the single,
you don't being that guy.
No, I dunno. I Dunno what to tell you. I can't tell you this.
So I feel like when you are, you know,
aside from just owning it to yourself to try to stay in shape,
when you're in a relationship with someone,
to just fucking let yourself go and just become a fad, fuck. And you know,
just not have the consideration that somebody is sort of obligated to have sex
with you to just try and remotely keep yourself looking halfway decent.
It's really a selfish fucking thing, you know?
But we live in the age of, um,
a lot of times the victim is, is the, is not, is,
is considered like the antagonizer.
You know what I mean?
I would never do that to me.
I would never just fucking put on a a hundred fucking pounds,
just come waddling into the fucking bedroom, you know,
rollover on top of her.
Since she would be completely grossed out in every woman listening to this,
probably just went, Eh,
picture that me a 100 pounds heavier,
naked sweating on my upper lip crawling into fucking bed. Yeah,
exactly. Isn't that disgusting? Well that, that's a two way street sweetheart.
You know, we don't want to see you come fucking waddling into the room.
You know, you hips taken out the fucking door jam. You know what I mean?
It's just, it's not a, it's not fair to either person.
Yeah. When you really look at it and nobody understands that more than gay guys.
I would say that gay guys have the most respect for the fact that someone's
going to hook up with them. You know what I mean?
I wonder if they had pound for pound in the best fucking shape than anybody else
or is it because they're trying to attract guys and they know guys are,
I can't even say that shallow cause they always say that guys is shallow when it
comes to that. We are, but like you fucking hold up something shiny.
A woman's like, hey what that, you know, they're just as bad. Right?
Oh Christ. I'm all over the map. All right. On trial for a joke. All right,
Bill,
did you hear about the entertainer who might get prosecuted for his poem that
trashed ahead of State? Uh, what country a,
they're calling him a comic, but I think maybe Europe's version of a comic,
not the traditional standup. Well, it depends on where you go. In Europe.
Europe is a, uh, you know, it's not the biggest continent, but that's,
it's a long fucking trip from Paris over to Moscow. I think.
Moscow's technically still in Europe, isn't it?
I know the west coast of Russia now you start getting into eastern Europe dude.
And you know,
I mean they still have vampires out there so you can only imagine how that would
affect the artist standup comedy. I don't know what I'm talking about.
All right.
And Angela Merkel gave the go ahead to the Turkish prime minister to make an
inquiry,
which basically means put on trial all because of a stupid poem.
Thoughts. I hate when people do that.
Thoughts talk about that. Um, yeah.
Lace a bunch of countries that are just getting their first taste of standup
comic comedy and they are going through their Lenny Bruce years.
Um, which is what happens that happened. Lenny Bruce, he was put on trial,
he was arrested for obscenity and all of that type of stuff.
This is what happens.
And once the government realizes that it's just jokes and that a standup comic
doing an hour of jokes is not going to cause a revolution and that they can
relax and continue to fuck over their own countrymen and sleep well at night
doing it, then they usually ease up on it. And, uh,
people are allowed to, um, you know, do standup comedy.
Like what's funny now is what's happening is there's this new, you know,
sort of, I dunno what you would call it, Lenny Bruce time,
but it's just more through people in the crowd though.
But it's not the government anymore, so it's really no big deal. It's just,
you know, people with agendas and websites and shit like that, you know,
clickbait, clickbait people. Right. All right.
Boyfriend wants to have sex with other girls. Um,
I want, if there's a way to basically support that person, Angela Merkel,
can I help pay for the lawyer kick in, you know,
all the comics around the world take four can throw 20 bucks at it and they
could tie it up in the Turkish courts. Can that happen? I don't fucking know.
Oh, you know what, I'm going to look that up.
I'm glad you brought that to my attention. I know that there was some,
somebody in Canada,
the same thing happen and it's one of those things where it's like you want to
talk about it,
but you also don't want to feed that fucking beast and give it all,
all types of notoriety. But then you're also going,
well that's a fellow comic going through that Shit.
There's gotta be a way in a stealth way to hopefully put that fire up.
Um, you know, when I was in India, the podcast I did, the guys over there,
they were going through some shit because they had a room,
they did a roast and everything was fine.
Everybody laughed and then they put it up on youtube and you know,
there's like 40 million different religions there and somebody complained and
you know,
they were in a, definitely a a, what's the word I should use? They were in a,
they weren't a situation over there when I, you know, which is hilarious.
Then I'm fucking walking down the street with them.
Okay.
Like, how am I going to get fucking arrested because I'm with you guys.
You know what's fucked up? I only spent 24 hours in India and I already miss it.
I really want to go back.
I had such a good time in the 24 hours despite the fact I had to get a piece of
paper to leave, which was really fucking creepy. But um,
okay.
I know it was weird man. I I didn't,
I didn't know what I was thought I was gonna think when I went there. But I,
I felt an odd connection when I went there. Um,
which is one of the coolest things when you travel. Like when you go,
every place you go to, it's going to be great when you actually go to a place.
Like why is this fucking place feeling like a like feeling like Whoa,
like a home.
Like I relate to these people more so than a lot of countries I've been to.
I was over there going like,
Oh that guy reminds me of rich foss maybe cause I hung out with a bunch of
comics. I have no idea. Anyways, boyfriend wants to have sex with other girls.
Hi Bill. Hi Bill. Um,
my boyfriend and I had been together for over two years.
Recently we had broken up for a little less than a month,
but we started talking again.
We broke up because although he loves me and wants to be with me
[inaudible] um, he still wants to have sex with other girls.
Our sex life isn't a problem because we fuck on a daily basis.
Most of the twice a day she was supposed to right time.
She was supposed to write time most of the time,
twice a day and he always says on the best he will ever slash will have.
He also believes that there is a very slim possibility that there might be
something better for him and then he wants to experience other people before
possibly spending the rest of his life with me.
He's 25 years old so he is pretty scared about staying with one person for the
rest of his life.
We are both not ready for marriage or that type of relationship,
but I feel that ending a two and a half year relationship over his urges isn't
the right thing. Especially since he still loves me and wants to be with me.
He's pretty unhappy,
but he knows that being with other people won't help because he will feel the
exact same way as he does. Now.
He tells me that I am amazing and beautiful and he wants to have a perfect
relationship,
so I don't understand why he wants to leave that for something that is most
likely going to be shittier.
I can't go through another breakup with him because it was horrible.
A while we were broken up, he did have sex with one girl and to multiple girls,
but I didn't feel any better and he was still unhappy without me. Please help.
I don't know what to do and maybe this can help them as well. Thanks a bunch.
Ah, well first of all, I'm not a fucking relationship expert, but, uh,
first of all, I got to give him Kudos for just being honest,
saying that this is what I want to do. Um,
well I'll talk to you cause he, you, he didn't write in.
So I would just say that, um,
unfortunately this is where he is at 25 and um,
you are not.
So if he wants to fucking go out and do whatever the fuck he wants to do,
you know, let him and then I think you should get on with your life.
But I don't think it's healthy for you to have him keep,
keep calling you during this time when he's out there fucking other people,
but still fucking with your emotions.
So I think you let them go and let him go do whatever the fuck he wants to do
and, but there's, you don't have any contact with them. Um,
that might be a guy thing where you need some sort of closure or some shit and
gradually talk and then talk less and less and less. I Dunno,
I'm a fucking psycho when it comes to that shit. So that's what I would do.
Um, I would say at this point,
what he's doing is he's trying to do what's right for him.
So you have to do what's right for you. Um,
he's putting himself first and his wants first,
so you should do the same thing and there's nothing wrong with what he's doing.
Um,
he could have fucking lied and said that he didn't have urges and then gone and
fucked around and you know,
okay.
I know, no matter what, he was going to end up hurting it, but he did it.
He did it. He did it the right way. He told you he broke up with you. And
um, yeah, he's got to go figure some shit out.
But I don't think he needs to be calling you up and re talking to you after a
month and getting your heart going again and giving you hope. And then,
but I don't know what I want to do, but I do love you. But again,
yeah, go fuck yourself with your wishy washy shit. All right. You know,
you're beautiful, you're young, you've got your whole life ahead of Ya.
You know, fuck them. Just fucking,
I don't know.
Why don't you have a little you time over the next two to three months,
see what you're at. Make a little list, figuring out what you want out of life.
You know, who knows, who knows? Maybe he'll come back to, you'd be like,
you know what? It sucked and you want to take him back. Maybe you won't, but a,
I think you need to focus on yourself and not him. That's a,
that's what I would do. Um, cause you didn't pull the trigger. He did sell.
There's no guilt on your end, but um,
it's a shitty thing to do to do that to somebody and then come back like a month
later and in drag you through that hell all over again,
but then not get back with you and make some sort of a commitment to just go
back and be like,
oh, you know, I hooked up with one person. It's still miss you.
You know, cause then you're going to be like, yeah. So what does that mean?
Does that mean he loves me? And you gotta sit there playing that mental tennis.
Fuck all that. Fuck all that. Yeah. Right there. Wishy washy. We'll see ya.
Okay.
Just tell them what you need. You need, yeah, 100% commitment. That's it.
You're either in it or you're out of it. I respect you.
The fact that you're honest, but you know,
I know I don't need you fucking hemming and hawing every fucking four weeks
dragging me back down to that emotional pit. I'm done. Get on with your life.
That's what I would do, you know, as fucking jackass.
And then the second you're getting on with your life, he won't want to lose you.
Then he'll come back and just so we won't lose one of those fucking guys.
That's what I'm thinking. Um, yeah, I would,
I would get on with your life. That's what I would do.
I hope that's good advice. I had no idea. All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Thank you guys for listening and thank you to everybody from the bottom of my
hat who watched the first season of emphasis for family. Uh,
we're really gonna try to outdo what we did in the first season and, uh,
try and make them as funny as possible. All right. That's it.
Go fuck yourselves. And I'll check in audio on Thursday. See Ya.